a so-called spy balloons
um have we looked into this into the UK
have you talked to the intelligence
military about whether the possibility
that some of these balloons or Chinese
balloons have been in the UK's out of
space well I want people to know that
we'll do whatever it takes to keep the
country safe we have something called
the quick reaction alert Force which
involves typhoon planes which are kept
on 24 7 Readiness to police our airspace
which is incredibly important I can't
obviously comment in detail on National
Security matters but we're in constant
touch with our allies and as I said
we'll do whatever it takes to keep the
country safe but just specifically you
today you do not know of any instance of
of spy balloons being spotted over UK
airspace as I said I wouldn't comment in
detail on security matters but people
should be reassured that we have all the
capabilities in place to keep the
country safe including the quick
reaction alert Force which has typhoon
planes which can police are skies on 24
7 Readiness but more generally we're in
touch with our allies and and we'll make
sure sure that the country is always
protected now just on Richard chop the
chairman of the BBC lots of questions
over the weekend about his position not
least of all because a select committee
of MPS including conservatives said that
essentially he had made mistakes do you
have confidence in the BBC chairman do
you think he's undermining BBC
impartiality so look this relates to a
process that happened before I was prime
minister obviously it's currently being
looked at by the independent Office of
Public appointments and that process is
ongoing so I can't speculate before
pre-judge the outcome of that but it's
an independent process it's going to
look at it and make sure that everything
was followed correctly or the rules and
procedures were adhered to and obviously
we'll wait for that report okay just two
final questions prime minister first of
all one on apparently there's brexit
meeting that took place relatively
recently did you know about it do you
sanctioned Michael Gove to go and talk
to other MPS you know I I was proud to
vote for brexit and now as prime
minister I'm Keen to make sure that we
deliver the benefits of it now we've
already done that when we've taken
control of our migration system for
example we're rolling out free ports
across the country which are creating
jobs and investment and now what we want
to do is make sure that we drive growth
in our economy by seizing the
opportunities of brexit to do things
differently we have a law that's going
through Parliament that will enable us
to do that and whether it's in life
sciences so we have faster drug trials
or whether it's in data and Technology
doing things differently so that we can
create jobs and prosperity across the
country
then it's not about the meeting this is
what I'm talking about what the
government is doing and that's making
sure that we capitalize on the benefits
of brexit trade deals that we're signing
all around the world and constantly in
dialogue with other partners as we speak
to increase the links between the UK and
countries everywhere that's good for
people's jobs here at home those are
just a few of the things that we can do
differently because of brexit and we're
going to keep delivering those benefits
for the British people cool and just
very finely the times today are saying
that water companies are going to avoid
big fines we know some of them have
sewage into into rivers and to Lakes
other government prepared to water down
these fines I think that that reporting
is is categorically not true right I
want to actually would welcome tougher
fines for water companies and that's
what we're putting in place not only are
we holding them to account for putting
in place the largest investment in our
water infrastructure in decades 56
billion pounds of investment that we're
expecting the water companies to put in
we will hold them to account for their
part in reducing the overflows and there
will be very significant fines for them
if they don't do their part in this
that's what the government is delivering
and that's what I'm committed to doing
so our political correspondent LED
Spates joins me now from Westminster and
watching uh the Prime Minister Rishi
sunak there um Liz he he spoke quite a
bit there didn't he about China UK
relations after other spy Blues what did
you take from that
well first of all uh just from the
series of questions and answers there
you see the many issues that Rishi sunak
has on his play Aid to Turkey and Syria
spy balloons he also has this issue of
the BBC chairman hanging over him as
well on this issue a spy balloons from
China I think fair to say the Prime
Minister trying to put forward a calming
message on this he said that the UK will
do whatever it takes to keep people safe
and to monitor its airspace he couldn't
give an answer and said he didn't want
to give an answer because it would be
too much detail on UK Security on
whether any of these objects have been
spotted in the UK but he said that we
are as a nation keeping in touch with
allies on this issue at the moment so
the first time the Prime Minister has
responded to this issue since we've
heard from the defense secretary this
morning Ben Wallace that he has in
response launched a Security review